hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
I'm Dave Reuben I've got Cara Santa
Maria max Luger veer with me and we got
a bunch of great stories for you in the
internet so we gotta move fast here we
go okay the the Queen has almost been
coronated that's right Hillary Clinton
everything's about 2016 it seems
preordained already as bonkers as that
may be and CNN is gonna do a documentary
about her a little bit before the
election at NBC is going to do a
miniseries about her and this has the
RNC all in their panties are in a bunch
and rinse Priapus who is the head of the
RNC although his name sort of sounds
like a bad guy in Harry Potter he's very
upset about this and the RNC wants to
boycott the debates over this and CNN
has issued a statement instead of making
premature decisions about a project that
is in the very early stages of
development and months from completion
we would encourage the members of the
Republican National Committee to reserve
judgment until they no more should they
decide not to participate in the debates
on CNN we would find it curious as
limiting their debate participation
seems to be the ultimate to service to
voters okay so that's CNN's statement
NBC News they said well we're not in
cahoots with NBC entertainment which I'm
not sure about that because Leno
interviewed Obama last night so I'm
pretty sure he's now the White House
chief correspondent for NBC anywho this
is a lot of buzz for Hillary Clinton
before the buzz has even begun in years
out is this stuff just so stupid and
just a culmination of everything that's
wrong with our media and the politics
yes no it's insane
what a silly bullying tactic on behalf
of the RNC I mean it's like where are
they like preschoolers in a sandbox like
it doesn't make any sense yeah I mean I
think Priebus is I don't know whether
it's legitimate or not I don't think
it's legitimate but as concerned about
you know major news organizations coming
out or appearing to come out on the side
of a particular candidate and announce
their candidacy yet and right we have no
idea who's going to be in these debates
but I I think it's it's funny that CNN
statement it had a little snark in it
yeah
and I I think truth be told I mean come
on
it is doing a disservice to the RNC if
they decide not to air to pay on this
like large failing as it may be news
network because where else are they
gonna go are they gonna start having RNC
debates on Fox News is that the only
Avenue they're gonna be able to take now
right and that right there you can only
go to their friendly people are the
Democrats are gonna say well we're only
gonna do it on MSNBC
but I sort of agree with them in some
slight thing here because whether
they're a glowing documentary that's you
know only saying nice things about her
or whether the miniseries is all great
about her or not it seems to me that any
publicity is good publicity it just
builds up the the machine that is
Hillary right yeah it's like the the
what are the pony show that is politics
and the 24 hour news cycle you know it's
like they sort of go hand in hand and
one fuels the fire of the other right
that if Hillary is presented in a more
critical more straightforward and
critical light that it's really going to
play into her favor I mean it what is
the alternative here is it that they
want tit for tat so like oh you were to
a miniseries about Hillary we want a
miniseries about Chris Christie well I'm
sorry but Hillary has a really long
record and she is a very established
politician and her her kind of life it
is it has contributed enough that I
think it warrants a miniseries or a
special you know in it there's there's
no reason to believe that these networks
are in cahoots with like the the DNC on
the 2016 election cycle that's crazy
so does this just go to like typical
Republican talking points which is the
media's against us so it's sort of like
they're just hopping on this to be like
see we told you the media hates us yeah
I don't know I mean it's a documentary
that I would watch you know yeah I don't
know I mean it's sad it's sad that it's
really just come down to bickering yeah
what do you say Reince Priebus is like
the worst RNC Chairman of all what what
is the deal maybe you know somebody
tweeted that if you take all the vowels
out of his name it actually goes tits
RNC PRBS I mean that's pretty
that's pretty freakin amazing isn't it
they'd like made this guy in a lab but
are you so let's talk about Hillary
though in a bigger sense like really are
we just coronating a queen is there any
chance what do you think the actual
chances are that she is not the next
president I don't know I think it's
really early a lot can happen in three
years yeah a lot can happen and I think
the voting public is really fickle and
so if there's some sort of big scandal
that could take her out of there I mean
it could very well happen I think it's
hard to say yeah right now I think she
looks like the best candidate but look
back during the primaries when Barack
Obama ran for the first time she was the
she was the runner at the contender
there I mean she has been in that slot
for a really long time yeah do you think
that the final part of this is just that
this is just typical like not only the
political end of it but just for the
networks that NBC's purging viewers
CNN's purging viewers so it's almost
like they just say they're gonna do this
stuff because that then just creates
buzz in and of it so the controversy is
just good for the network even right
yeah it's true I mean the world we live
in you know facts are delivered at 140
characters on Twitter instantaneously so
I think that you know to stir up a
little drama works in their favor yeah
you know and so that's just the nature
of the world we live in we doubt that
CNN our NBC even thought this would be
drama I don't think that they decided to
do this kind of programming schedule
hoping that it would ruffle the feathers
of the RNC I think that the RNC making a
big deal out of it kind of came maybe
not as a surprise but like was an
annoyance to that more than anything
right but I think it was a good point
about how who would they choose on the
Republican side to do a movie about like
are you just gonna show Chris Christie
going a Golden Corral or like Rand Paul
like learning from his dad in the dark
right exorcisms in college so that would
be in trouble is that not a bigger story
but I know Bobby Jindal is like
fascinated me he was gonna be he was the
golden boy they said he was gonna be
there Obama
that speech that yeah yeah make a movie
based on those exorcisms I mean I feel
like that would be more interesting than
the conjuring which got tons my song I
was totally bored by it totally there
was no political angle